it keeps rewriting itself to counter my
commands this has something to do with
computers
hack them all hi i'm sammy camkar sammy
is the co-founder of open pass security
and a computer hacker i'm back to talk
about more hacking scenes in tv shows
and movies
breaking into a government system the
x-files this has something to do with
computers
the internet actually the arpanet you
can access it through the internet
i want to believe but this clip isn't
too realistic
arpanet is essentially what the internet
came from darpa the us government agency
created arpanet
and that bubbled into the internet and
became publicly available when the
x-files came out
arpanet was no longer in existence isn't
this something you could
i mean how do you say it hack into i'm
sorry i think this is the end of the
line
how you say that's what she says she
says how you say hack
how do you say it hack into but how you
say is what you say in other languages
when you don't know right what did you
do
oh it's a government system i know a
couple of logging out tricks with vms
version 5.
if you're using a password that you know
then i don't really consider that
hacking
what is that it's an encrypted file why
would your three-year-old have an
encrypted file than a secret defense
department database
can you decode it there's another issue
here in that they find
a file that's encrypted that by itself
is not
too unrealistic they're showing the file
in ascii format
can you print it out for me but when you
print it out that's going to be useless
information
and that's because many of the
characters that would be in an encrypted
file
are not visible in an ascii format so
you end up with
things like periods which may or may not
be a period or it could be a totally
different
uh character or bike so your
ex-boyfriend is into computers
i would totally say that wait your
boyfriend's into computers i should meet
him
locking down a system jurassic park
[Music]
in this clip it looks like newman you
know who i mean
is kind of running around activating or
deactivating certain types of locks
but at some point someone else tries to
run a command like access grid
and that causes an access denied but
then he gets a series of messages
so this doesn't look too realistic just
in the fact that he's getting
access to nine messages without a
password and he's also then getting a
message in a loop which is just
less likely to happen in a realistic
scenario this reminds me of
some of the clips that we saw in the
first technique critique when
we were seeing really just a lot of
pop-ups that would occur stop the
pop-ups
and a lot of videos typically that will
hackers will put onto
devices that's not something we
generally see in the real
it's a world system it's all the files
of the whole park
the girl gets to the computer and says
it's a unix system it doesn't look like
a unix system which is
typically a terminal or console window
but it actually is
unix it tells you everything i got to
find the right file
the 3d interface that she's using is a
legitimate software that a company
called sgi made many years ago
it's not something anyone actually uses
it was really just about proof of
concept of
using a 3d file system the reason no one
would ever use it is because it takes
forever
to navigate a 3d system when you're just
trying to find a file take this hack of
graph
decrypting a file the code might be an
error in the video compression i can fix
that
maybe but i would need to get online
[Music]
here we see jesse taking a corrupted
video file
and for a moment we see him start
running a program called
ffmpeg and he essentially tries to
remove corruption from this video file
and that's totally reasonable
ffmpeg is meant for all sorts of
modifications or alterations to video
images and audio
so for example if you have something
that's corrupt you could take all the
frames that are not corrupt
extract them and then reconstruct all of
those frames into a single video
there was a part that was inaccurate in
where we saw
the red green and blue channels all
visually come up while that would be
possible to do
ffmpeg the tool itself is a terminal
based tool so it's all text based
despite operating on video image and
audio can you fix that
maybe but i would need to get online he
has to go online but if he already has
that ffmpeg tool
downloaded to his machine there's
actually no reason for him to go online
so who knows what he was actually doing
sometimes you do hear of hackers
getting sentenced not to use computers
or be on the internet unfortunately that
occurred to me
earlier in my life for several years i
don't know if we want to go into it
now i'm allowed to be on the internet
hardware hacking
firewall i need my daughter's mp3 player
he uses a hard drive
here we see jack stanfield using his
daughter's ipod to store data
while under duress in a kidnapping
situation this is the scanner head
from the fax machine and you'll capture
the images of the account numbers
off the server screen and transfer them
to this that's totally realistic if you
think about an mp3 it's just a digital
format of
audio and audio is really just an analog
signal so you can convert that into a
digital format and just like you can
convert any other data
into some digital format but they're
still just images what are you going to
do with them
we use an ocr program to convert it to
data that the computer can use
he also mentions using ocr which is
object character recognition
so if i were to take a screenshot of a
bank account it's an image
there's not actually text in it even
though i can read the text ocr software
would then convert that and extract all
of the text from it without me having to
type it in manually
10 000 songs 10 000 account goods it
doesn't know the difference
the only thing he doesn't go over here
is how he converts
the images from the scanner into the
mp3s you do need some conversion to
occur
so that needs to be a computer or a
microcontroller or something it should
work
packing a smart fridge silicon valley
hello my cool friend
hello huh yang
hmm ah huh you attack and destroy my
refrigerator
and you misspell my name essentially
smart fridges themselves are really just
computers they're running some operating
system maybe a stripped down version of
linux
i was able to brute force the backdoor
password to that chrome piece of in
under 12 hours
what guilfoyle is saying is that he was
able to brute force
the password all that means is he went
through millions and millions of
passwords trying to authenticate through
some mechanism that the fridge exposed
maybe it's connected to the wi-fi
network and it has a port open that you
can then connect
to that is a possible scenario a
backdoor is
a way to log in or authenticate into a
system
without going through the traditional
mechanism
so maybe a website has a username and
password field
a backdoor would be a special url that
you wouldn't need to enter any username
or password but i added a little visual
flair
huh hacking an atm pin
terminator 2 judgement day please insert
your stolen card now
they insert a device that looks like a
credit card tied to a computer with a
ribbon cable and it looks to do some
type of brute force of the pin code go
baby go baby go baby
right easy money
some of this could be possible the
problem is the pin code has nothing to
do with the data on the credit card
nor is it ever inserted within the
credit card slot those are two
independent systems
what they're doing here with the pan
just isn't talking to the right system
so they'd have to be plugged into
something else
in order to even attempt an attack like
this could you learn this stuff from
anywhere from my mom
destroying a hard drive the core this is
the fbi we have awards
in this scene the main character is
trying to wipe delete
purge any day they can from a number of
different data storage
types
[Music]
he takes some pretty big magnets and he
goes over what
i assume are hard drives which would
work for traditional spinning platter
hard drives that would erase a lot of
the data as the data is kept in magnetic
fields
if i had to destroy something like a
traditional spinning hard drive then i
probably would do something similar by
using magnets but ideally i would also
want to open it after the fact
and then crush it into bits the more
small pieces you have
the less data someone will be able to
extract and be able to put them together
he also throws some cds or dvds into a
microwave the data there is actually
stored within the polycarbonate so
if he had a sufficient time to melt it
he could make it disappear but
it just depends on that amount of time
he also deleted some data just using
software now a quick software delete in
the period of time he had which was only
a few seconds
while that appears to delete the files
it actually doesn't delete the data
all it does is tell your hard drive or
your computer that the data in this
sector
is now free in order to actually delete
data from a drive
you actually need to overwrite that data
and typically you'll want to override it
several times
then for a safe measure hit it with a
hammer a bunch of times
i know these look like computers totally
not
faraday cage enemy of the state this is
where i work
completely secure copper wire mesh keeps
the
radial signals out he says this copper
wire cage or a faraday cage
keeps radio signals out normally that is
true when you have
a conductive mesh or a metallic mesh the
only thing that can penetrate that mesh
are wavelengths that are essentially
smaller than the mesh
itself so the holes themselves but in
this case there's a lot of
radio frequency that can fit in that
wavelength so
really even something like five
gigahertz wi-fi would be able to
penetrate that mesh if the mesh were
smaller then
it would be able to block a lot more
radio frequency hate to see the chicken
that lives in this coupe
acoustic analysis eagle eye
sir all the threats we've been tracking
chatter also
in this scene a couple of things are
happening there is a
voiceover ip phone that they ultimately
disconnect to prevent someone from
snooping or
enabling the microphone it shows that
the camera is essentially able to read
lips
really creative and absolutely doable
with software today
what they didn't expect and which is
really creative
is they're actually using acoustic
analysis
to look at vibrations off the coffee cup
that was there
so when you're speaking or when
someone's speaking they are moving air
molecules
and that's going at a certain frequency
based off the frequency of their sound
when that hits something like the drink
you're actually able to
convert that physical change of that
liquid
back into audio because essentially it's
moving at the frequency of sound and if
you can visually see that you can then
convert that
visual frequency back into the frequency
of sound and hear it so
it's actually very creative but it is
doable denial of service attack
ralph breaks the internet
insecurity detected
[Music]
in this clip we see some sort of
malicious system that
is finding this insecurity in ralph
and they're essentially duplicating
ralph and duplicating the sense security
which then takes over
all sorts of websites stops it starts
interfering with people's web browsers
the internet is under assault as a
massive denial of service attack crashes
servers across the web
denial of service typically isn't going
to do something
manipulative like alter your web browser
or alter a video feed instead
its goal is one simple thing and that's
to bring a system down
while this is uh pretty unrealistic
i think we can give ralph a pass here
just for his insecurity
hijacking a tv channel v for vendetta
dad what's wrong with the telly good
evening
in this scene we see someone essentially
taking over a tv station
in this case i don't consider this
hacking because they essentially already
have the capability they're in the
station
and they have the ability to already
override the video that's been playing
right now what makes it a little less
unlikely is that they're also taking
over billboards and often those are
coming off a separate feed
off some pre-recorded video granted
those could be
based off of live video as well in tim
burton's batman we do see something
similar where a
live newscast is taken over by the joker
now that is actually a lot more
realistic and is an actual hack
because often live broadcasts are being
aired over radio
so if someone can intercept and by
intercept i just mean
send a stronger signal then they can
actually override that signal if they
can hit the receiver
and take over that so that is something
that can happen and has happened in the
past
he don't look happy he's been using
brand x
stock market hack who am i
[Music]
in this clip they're on the roof of what
appears to be a stock exchange
and they're somehow connecting to the
network this by itself is going to be a
little challenging
because there are many different
networks and just being on the roof is
typically not enough to jump on the
network
we do see them run something called bash
buffer overflow.sh
and some number and buffer overflow is a
common technique to
exploit various types of software by
overflowing their memory so much that
you
get to a point in memory that you can
tell the processor where to run
code and you can then point that back to
the original memory you overflowed
and that's now your code so it's a way
to take over a computer
just by inputting some data what they're
demonstrating is that they're able to
connect to
and then run their own code and run
their own instructions
[Music]
we're also seeing essentially video of a
graph
and that chart is probably going to be
extracted from
some other location maybe from a website
or from some other feed so it might be
possible but it's going to be
challenging to do this
autonomous vehicle exploitation fate of
the furious
there's over a thousand of them hack
them all
in this clip we see a bunch of cars
getting
hacked and taken over some of this could
be possible
and there's a pretty incredible
demonstration of this type of attack
where they were able to take
a jeep that was driving on the road with
someone from wired inside
and they were able to take that car over
they first started just
controlling the windshield wipers
adjusting the radio
and then actually started messing with
the controls of the vehicle like the
throttle
and that's because some vehicles do have
these components computerized
however what they're showing here where
they're just arbitrarily choosing
cars to take over is really unlikely
because it's a lot of effort and it's
typically a targeted attack you have to
really know the vehicle that you
are trying to get to first
you see a bunch of cars that are
actually parked and they start driving
well that's not going to happen if you
have something like an e-brake as far as
i know
today there aren't many vehicles with a
computerized e-brake
so we're just seeing way too many
vehicles doing way too many things they
simply don't have the capability to do
add buckle up if i were you credential
hack
mission impossible ghost protocol
in this scene we see ethan hunt going
into
uh government building he reveals his
credentials
and the person working behind the desk
starts scanning the credentials
he looks at kind of what percentage of
this hacking
is being done this seems pretty unlikely
for a couple of reasons
for one when you're talking about a
credential or
authorization system it's likely not
going to be on some wireless network
even if you do have a wireless network
in a government building it's again
likely not tied to a security checkpoint
another problem here is that we see a
percentage
of completion you almost never have
percentages when you're talking about
hacking either you have found a
mechanism to get in
or or you haven't so the loading bar in
hacking scenes is
usually not very accurate i love your
disguise by the way
max boof mr robot
[Music]
in this scene we see darlene take a
little
magnetic read head and take a hotel card
and scan it and then store it into a
device called mac spoof
then she goes up to the hotel room
and she essentially hits play which
either replays that or it brute forces
the code and that unlocks the door and
that is something that can absolutely
occur max boof is a device i personally
created and it's designed to essentially
allow
to perform penetration testing around
different types of mag stripes
primarily around credit cards the device
itself is an electromagnet and what all
that means is it's able to create a
magnetic
field both north and south the writers
of mr robot were really creative here
and asked if this were possible on hotel
mag stripes
and it's entirely possible and they
actually came up with the idea
of taking that same device and using it
here in a hotel to brute force through
various numeric codes for a room just by
having somebody else's room card
and that's a totally feasible scenario
hacking at an apple store
captain america the winter soldier
now he's trying to hide something can i
help you guys with anything
oh no my fiance was just helping me with
some honeymoon destinations
it seems that really what they're trying
to do is just hide who they are
and what they're doing so they're going
to an apple store so they can take the
ip address of the apple store rather
than doing it say from their
home or office or captain america
network how much time we have uh about
nine minutes
from now generally you wouldn't want to
do it in an apple store for one they're
gonna have a lot of cameras
so all they have to do is correlate the
time the computer and then look at the
video feed and they might be able to
capture who is there
oh maybe we can find out where it came
from there was an art
prank done many years ago at an apple
store in new york the creator kyle
ended up getting the secret service sent
to his house so you probably don't want
to try this congratulations were you
guys thinking about going
new jersey if you did want to actually
perform attacks and
hide your ip address it would make more
sense to have some sort of device say a
raspberry pi computer connect it to a
solar panel
throw it on top of a store and then
connect to that
so that is now connecting to the free
wi-fi of
somewhere nearby and now you're sort of
proxied there's no video of you you're
not
at the store but you're taking advantage
of their ip address and now it's
going to be much harder to link back to
you the person who developed this is
slightly smarter than me
fishing attack ocean's eight
rihanna or nine ball is trying to fish
somebody she's constructing a
an email or message it has some link
that
the person clicks and then that person
had their
camera engaged and the video feed went
back to
nine ball that is pretty unlikely in
order to actually enable somebody's web
camera
you need to get code to execute on their
computer
that's usually very difficult when you
employ those attacks
and they get executed they're going to
be discovered pretty quickly if you
start using it and it's going to be
patched pretty quickly
so it's not to say it's not possible
it's just that once you start using
these types of attacks
you're essentially burning them
otherwise a phishing attack by itself
getting someone to click something or
visit a malicious link
that is pretty easy to do and that
happens honestly every day
discovering a worm hackers
it isn't a virus it's a worm here we see
zero cool doing some sort of
investigation
we do see a lot of algebraic formulas
unfortunately
which have really nothing to do with
what he's doing granted if you're
programming
you will be writing a lot of algorithms
but you're never doing it
in let's say the algebraic format that
they're showing it isn't a virus
it's a worm the worm eats a few cents
from each transaction
and when the worm's ready it zips out
with the money and erases its try
he says this is a worm and not a virus
and that seems true
essentially we think of a virus as some
piece of
software or malware that requires some
action by a user
in order for it to execute where a worm
is more likely something that requires
little to no action
in order to proliferate by this point
it's already running at twice the speed
is when it started when i was younger i
did accidentally release a worm
on a site popular many years ago called
myspace all it did was someone would
visit my profile without knowing it they
would add me as a friend and the code
would copy to their profile
that means when someone visits their
profile and the code would copy to their
profile
within about 24 hours over a million
people were infected
it said sami is my hero on all these
profiles and my myspace had to shut down
in order to remove this worm
unfortunately for me i couldn't touch a
computer for several years i wasn't
allowed on the internet
until i went back to a judge now we're
here
crash 1507 systems in one day
aptitude test snowden we're gonna start
with an aptitude test
the average test time is five hours
if you take more than eight you will
fail
i don't know whether after two tests
like this happen in government i can
only assume they do
i know with a lot of companies you will
go through some types of tests you will
be on the spot you will be given a
computer
or you'll be given a whiteboard and
they'll say okay do
x you know write some software to
perform this so
there are realistic tests like this
it's actually interesting because
they're running legitimate commands we
see nmap run a few times we see
tar an archiving utility used to
compress some data
and then extract that data a lot of this
was extremely realistic
i'm really just nitpicking but a couple
of those commands had a verbose flag
enabled which should have output a lot
more data but they didn't output any
data but
otherwise it seemed like a reasonable
clip eyes on screens
don't have enough space to do all the
other clips
does anyone have an ipod
conclusion hacking itself is not always
the most glamorous to look at however we
are seeing
more and more hardware type hacking
where people are taking physical devices
and moving hacking into the real world
and that by itself i think looks more
interesting
all right guys from the top